all right so we're gonna watch is a
[ __ ] apology video see woody see if
this is sincere at all is Logan apology
I see having seen that one video now I'm
like his eye I'm very skeptical so we
came across that day that was was
obviously unplanned the reactions you
saw a few I should never post the video
I should put the cameras down stopped
recording a lot of things I shouldn't
but I didn't this depression or suicide
but most importantly my fans are
defending my actions the goal with my
content is always to entertain to push
the boundaries to be all inclusive in
the world I live in I share almost
everything I do
the intent is never to be heartless
cruel or malicious
[Music]
I'm disappointed in myself I promise to
be better it's so conflicting isn't it
yeah I mean as far as apologies go it's
a pretty good apology yeah it's always
good when someone's just like I'm not
here to make excuses I messed up and I'm
sorry about that yeah at the same time
and I've you know people I admire have
messed up lately too and have had to do
this and this will only mean anything if
he actually puts the work in to making
things better and damage done as far as
that video is concerned it's like I
don't keep up to date with this guy's
channel so I don't and I'm not about to
yeah I don't know it's still not my Maia
I think he this guy should take a break
he has the money to take a break for
like a few weeks or like a couple weeks
at least go away and then over the
course of time show that you are
changing and show that you are improving
like you'll have to you'll have to work
to earn back the respect of people but
most importantly it'll only work if he's
really doing it if he's really working
on himself trying to you know come
across in a more sincere way or whatever
you know it's like this could be an
emotionally challenging time for the guy
that's the thing is when you see that
other video and everything I've heard
about this guy yeah then I see this I'm
like well it's hard to know for sure how
genuine he actually is it's the hardest
part about this yeah is he being that
genuine I don't know I have no idea yeah
totally and and I feel like the
follow-through is gonna have a lot to do
with that I don't know exactly what he's
supposed to do now and I feel like going
away for a while is sort of part of the
solution or changing the tone of what he
does a little bit to be a bit more broad
a bit less about everything and yeah
like I don't know again I I feel like
the sentiment is all goods it's
certainly on pitch especially because so
many people were apologizing for stuff
lately you get to see sort of who's
doing it right who's doing it wrong I
don't know what this is worth really I
mean I hope he's sincere and that's
about the best I can do
I don't care for the guy this is a TV I
can't I can't help but have that part of
me that feels a little bad for the guy
just a little bit
oh yeah it's a compassion inside of me
that's like well if he is being real
that side of me feels bad for him for
having a slip up and doing something
stupid in the moment because we've all
had some versions that we already
opinions like that in this arena
especially yeah because that's part of
the the difficulty in having such an
easy barrier between you and everyone
yeah because he doesn't owe me anything
so I have no reason to hold anything
against the guy yes he owes me nothing
yeah it's the people that he's directly
offended that he has to earn forgiveness
from the people who had people deal with
suicide little live people have have
dealt with suicide be lost people
suicide is huge on YouTube so he has a
fan base that probably isn't involved in
that yeah and this video got shown to a
lot of people who aren't followers of
the guy so these are the people who have
to earn as free who asks our forgiveness
from this is just making it so that I'm
not gonna watch your channel yeah yeah
you know really grow yeah those guys to
make a difference how big is the end of
his career I don't I don't you know I
don't care for career ends I don't care
if your boobs I just I don't care yeah
I'll take a hit from this because it
just will very he's very disingenuous
and very video alone has like half of
them are like hundreds of thousands of
dislikes I'm pretty sure I'm not even
gonna go read the comments it's just
crazy to me and I mean you know I I do
for what for what it's worth you know
it's always good when someone's like hey
fans of mine please don't defend my ass
because I did mess up like that's
important it's important it's not a
questionable part about this guy is he
said a lot of [ __ ] in that vlog that was
so obviously this is what I have to say
yeah and so now I'm sitting here going
you have to say thing or do you really
feel this yeah and I guess only time
will tell
only time will genuinely tell him I
don't personally know the guy I don't
well yeah and any apology for for
something like that is only ever the
first step you know it's not the
solution it's just admitting that you
have a problem yeah and then going from
there's love going into the new year and
messages of continued right
traverse god ah PewDiePie's racists
everyone in hollywood sexually
assaulting someone logan paula has no
feelings for dead people i guess is
crazy to me man
oh yeah crazy to me just doesn't stop
people and now it's not even just like
sexual assault cuz if for a while I was
like it seemed like that was the only
bad behavior thing happening on mascara
now it's like widening out to just
people or messing up left and right in
in the public space one of my favorite
musicians just a couple weeks ago got in
trouble for kicking somebody guys calm
it down [ __ ] alright yep this video is
over